nouveau témoignage au procès villemin
sur la mort du petit grégory mais les
médecins légistes entendu aujourd'hui
ont fait aveu d'ignorance ils ont été
incapables de dire quand et comment le
petit garçon a été assassiné isabelle
steiss eric de l'agneau au commencement
de l'enquète il y avait deux médecins
légistes dont le docteur pages elle
c'est elle qui a pratiqué l'autopsié de
grégory il portait un bonnet un anorak
il avait une cordelette autour du cou
des mains et des chevilles les liens
n'était pas du tout serré le juge
lambert lui aussi était là il ne voulait
pas du tout qu'on fasse les prélèvements
accuse le docteur pagelles ça nous a
surpris
on a insisté on a juste obtenu
l'autorisation de prélever du sang et
les poumons en omettant de faire tous
les prélèvements
on a réduit les possibilités de faire la
lumière enchaîne le professeur lebreton
l'enfant noyé dans les eaux de la
vologne
je dis non il n'y avait pas de corps
étrangers dans les poumons
le docteur marc un juge le propose son
confrère excessif mais il s'étonne
pourtant que l'enfant ne se soient pas
débattues pour se dégager de ses liens
il ne portait pas de marque
grégory était il inconscient c'est
probable mais c'est pas sûr les
questions fusent mais chaque réponse des
médecins dans comme un aveu
d'impuissance
neuf ans après les faits tout le
problème est de savoir si l'enfant est
mort noyé avant d'être jeté dans la
vologne a résumé l'un des médecins
terrible constat dans une bataille
d'experts où la seule certitude
aujourd'hui est une autopsie bâclé qui a
sans doute faussé toute l' enquête